rolls are fundamentally happy creatures
so complaining does not come naturally
to us even when things go wrong and
that's tough when you're a ruler cuz you
never know how your people really feel
about the job you're doing
which is why we trolls decided to invent
an anonymous survey called Royal review
means oh hey Dad rhombus poppy your
stress booking again what me stress
booking I know you want to protect the
trolls from a bad bellow bug day but
it's not worth risking our lives over
agreed off to get the triple rainbow
maker Oh fine if you won't listen to
what I'm saying
will you listen to what I'm singing
we're putting our lives in danger all
for some silly rainbow poppy let's not
go
stay safe with me that was beautiful but
everything will be just fine long stick
with me online whether the weather's
fair
or fine and/or they'll be always a clear
blue sky and sun shining yellow and
bright behind even the darkest clouds
there's always light of fire things have
never been so dire I can't stand any
more positive sir but all I hear is your
laughter oh why is it so hard for you to
see
[Music]
we found the rainbow maker
Oh funny running into you come here
often
somebody's been workin out oh you
noticed but enough about my rock-hard
bod how are you my beautiful queen oh
guy you're hilarious
I've missed you shall we saunter ooh
sauntering that's my third favorite
walking style I think I felt a spark oh
you so poppy I've got a question for you
given that it's hug day I was wondering
if hey gang clown guy you're looking
damp as usual what are we up to we are
headed to Byrd cliff to catch the sunset
Byrd cliff you like birds don't you
branch
laughing branch birds terrify you huh I
don't have fears hey if you're too
scared feel free to sit this one out
what I'm not sitting anything out you're
acting really upbeat
he's probably just excited for hug day
speaking of which is your status Gladys
um I haven't hugged yet interesting and
she's not going to you don't think I'm
gonna get a hug no no no no no that's
not what I mean
well why wouldn't she branch I think
you're very huggable in fact there are
trolls who make your day brighter your
step lighter and that's what you do for
me that's so sweet
thank you I've been told I have the soul
of a poet why you little
oh look a mud puddle allow me to cover
it for you poppy
no allow me
branch I could have just walked around
that float over it - bird cliff he's
gonna take my hug not if I get there
first
[Music]
[Music]
branch what's wrong with you
yeah branch what's wrong he gave you his
hugged a hug when he knows full well
that I wanted to you do yeah of course
you're the most important person in my
life but I was so scared you'd say no
and now I blew it
why would I say no I was gonna ask you
you weren't you were way to finally put
it out there pal when I read your
journal I realized you needed a little
motivation you welcome
wait what this was all a trick you can
owe me one what a gun but her hug is
gone you hugged her no no no the rule on
Hyundai is that you can only hug one
troll hello I'm a cloud guy
what oh now your hug is gone aha but
look next time pal
if you love the movie get ready for more
[Applause]
[Music]
with the happiest glittery
[Music]
[Applause]
funniest singing Asst huggy asterick
ters ever
[Music]
coming to Netflix this January rolls the
beat goes every day the party's just
beginning all together human need
[Music]
through the garlic Harmon
[Music]
[Applause]
here
you